au revoir au président oui mais non pas
à monsieur le président jacques chirac
mais au président en version football
l'un des géants du foot français prend
sa retraite avec la coupe d'europe en
main et le sourire aux lèvres le
président curieux surnom présidence et
du glac imac images je crois que ça a
été le premier à sentir ce surnom tout
simplement parce qu'on avait créé une
association à marseille domine toujours
pour se retrouver pour orange l'ensemble
pour délirer un petit peu assez rebutant
pour s'amuser à partir de là je me suis
peu occupé m'appelait le président et
comme il n'a pas sa langue dans la poche
c'est tout le modèle à suivre
le président donc comme sur nous mais
cela aurait pu être le boss vu le
palmarès